74 einer der gefürchtesten mörder
großbritanniens
bei bayfield war einer der
gefährlichsten frauenmörder die england
je gesehen hat
vom mutmaßlichen serientäter
wenn wir diese person nicht fassen wird
es weitere opfer geben zum verurteilten
mörder zweier frauen und der schülerin
milly dowler doch man findet keinen
umgang damit warum warum an diesem tag
einblicke in wels düstere vergangenheit
villingen war ein pädophilen ring aktiv
völlig unbemerkt
er machte immer weiter und weiter wo
wird das aufhören es führte immer zum
selben ausgangspunkt es kam ein riesiges
netzwerk zum vorschein
zeuginnen die bisher nicht beachtet
wurden
sie bekamen ghb oder holt neu
verabreicht und wurden wie objekte
benutzt
übergriffe auf frauen sind trauriger
alltag aber wie kann ein gewalttäter wie
bayfield so lange unentdeckt bleiben
nur geübt um dann los zu ziehen und
ernst zu machen der kaltblütige täter
selbst war überzeugt niemals gefasst zu
werden
es ist die geschichte geheimer
unterlagen
ich bin an einer polizeiakte gekommen
insgesamt gab es 24 gewalttätige
übergriffe auf frauen viele von ihnen
wussten nicht dass bayfield als
verdächtig galt und eines mannes der es
offenbar genoss die polizei im dunkeln
tappen zu lassen
[Musik]
erst neun jahre nach milly dowler
tragischem tod wird ihr mörder zur
verantwortung gezogen
hier im verschlafenen wollten und es
verschwindet milly dowler am hellichten
tag
die ermittlungen sind zäh und werden
zusätzlich erschwert als sich
herausstellt dass journalisten und
detektive im auftrag der news of the
world ihre mailbox gehackt haben
monate später wird milly dowler leiche
gefunden von pilzsammlern nicht von der
polizei und jahre später erfolgte die
festnahme ihres mörders nur weil eine
völlig andere polizeidienststelle gegen
ihn wegen weiterer verbrechen ermittelt
jetzt fällt auf dass sie ganz in der
nähe seines damaligen wohnsitzes
verschwunden ist
neun jahre lang übersieht ihn die
polizei dabei sollen bereits bis zu 93
anzeigen gegen ihn vorgelegen haben
obendrein wurde am tag vor milly dowler
verschwinden einen entführungsversuch
gemeldet doch 2011 wird liebe fehlt ein
als heimtückisch und gefährlich
beschriebener mörder endlich für die
entführung und ermordung von milly
dowler verurteilt er wird den rest
seines lebens hinter gittern verbringen
nun können die menschen in den von ihm
heimgesuchten londoner vororten wieder
ruhig schlafen
daher hätte zweifellos weiter gemordet
er hätte noch mehr frauen getötet er
hätte nie und nimmer aufgehört
[Musik]
revival viert wuchs nicht weit von milly
dowler wohnort auf einige glauben er
hätte schon sehr früh geschmack am töten
gefunden
in hemsloh hieß könnte liebe fehlt
seinen ersten mord begangen haben
1980 erschüttert ein gewaltverbrechen
die anwohner
ich habe 40 jahre lang als kriminal
reporter gearbeitet diesen fall werde
ich nie vergessen petzi morris war eine
14 jährige schülerin aus
sie war an dem morgen ohne regenjacke
zur schule gegangen und nass geworden
sie wollte in der mittagspause schnell
nach hause um sich trockene kleidung
anzuziehen doch sie kam nie zu hause an
es wurde eine umfassende suche
eingeleitet mit hunderten polizisten und
freiwilligen aus der bevölkerung
[Musik]
48 stunden später wurde hier im
unterholz ihre leiche entdeckt die
todesursache sie war erwürgt worden und
die tatwaffe war eine damen strumpfhose
wer viel schulfreundin michelle witschen
erinnert sich an die ereignisse
es war beängstigend
während der draußen hans nur hits
spielen wird ganz in der nähe ein
mädchen getötet das war sehr sehr
beängstigend
denn du weißt nicht wer da draußen ist
weil ich beobachtet und darauf wartet
zuzuschlagen
patches mörder wird nie gefasst der fall
ist bis heute ungeklärt
sie war erst 14 jahre alt sie ging hier
im viertel auf die vierten comprehensive
school
interessanterweise war sie dort mit
einem gewissen anderen schüler bekannt
mit liebe erfährt
er schwänzte häufig den unterricht und
hans löw war einer der orte an denen er
solche tage gern verbrachte
war an dem tag nicht in der schule
gewesen
fakt ist bayfield kannte sie fakt ist er
sah sie jeden tag fakt ist sie wurde
dort ermordet wo sie beide lebten
bayfield hat es immer abgestritten und
der fall bleibt ungelöst so weit es geht
betrifft
ich sitze hier 40 jahre später und frage
mich was damals wohl passiert sein mag
mit all dem was wir jetzt über liebe
fehlt wissen wird klar auch kinder
können fähig seien absolut grausame
taten zu begehen
die wahl wurde damals nicht befragt ich
hoffe er war es nicht falls doch soll er
dazu stehen aber bei gott ich hoffe er
war es nicht aber
wenn doch wie wird ein kind zum mörder
[Musik]
ich wohnte in einer mietswohnung und
lebte in dem haus direkt gegenüber wir
konnten einfach zueinander über gucken
ich habe mich gut mit ihm verstanden das
hat einfach gepasst ich kriegt er war
ein kleiner kerl sehr dünn ein ziemlich
erwischt er war der kleinste von allen
wir durften nicht miteinander spielen
haben es aber trotzdem gemacht heimlich
hinter dem rücken unserer eltern letzten
endes wurde uns jeder kontakt untersagt
irgendwann hat meine mom ihm verboten zu
uns zu kommen
also bin ich immer zu ihm rüber
geschmissen
wie weit kommt am 17 mai 1968 in eisen
wurf im westen londons zur welt
euro lag er hatte eine schöne kindheit
in einer liebevollen stark zusammen
haltenden familie es hat ihn nie an
etwas gefehlt und alle gaben auf einen
der acht doch im alter von acht jahren
verschiebt sich das familiengefüge mit
dem frühen tod von bayfields vater
[Musik]
seine mutter war die materialien sie
hatte das sagen in der familie ihr wort
war gesetz
[Musik]
wird zu ihrem unangefochtenen lieblinge
er hatte offenbar eine enge wirklich
extrem enge bindung zu seiner mutter und
gott gott ja ihr geliebter kleiner
krieger er machte niemals etwas falsch
sie ließ ihm wohl viel durchgehen und
lobte ihn in den himmel so dass er das
gefühl bekam über jede kritik erhaben zu
sein
[Musik]
unter den kindern der nachbarschaft
kursieren viele gerüchte über liebe
erfährt
er wurde hier extrem gepiesackt er hatte
kaninchen hinten im garten in einer
hütte
es wurde herum erzählt er wurde eines
von ihnen
damit wurde er wirklich aufs schlimmste
drangsaliert
du kaninchen [ __ ] dhupia [ __ ] so was
halt
manchmal nahm ihn das sehr mit dann ging
er nicht raus diese kaninchen geschichte
wurde er nicht mehr los
sie war ihm verhasst
in serie in seinen jungen jahren erlebte
er einerseits eine intensive erhöhung
durch seine mutter und andererseits
außenseitertum unter gleichaltrigen
er gehörte nie richtig dazu
die kombination dieser gefühle die welt
gegen sich zu haben aber gleichzeitig
etwas besonderes zu sein kann menschen
zu großen anspornen aber in bern filz
fall hatte sie sehr destruktive ssig
bezogenes verhalten zufolge
activity
mit gerade 13 jahren hat berg fährt
erstmals mit der polizei zu tun jeff
edwards war jahrzehntelang kriminal
reporter
erhielt fiel schon in jungen jahren
immer wieder durch straftaten auf
er klaute autos und hatte ständig wegen
irgendetwas ärger mit dem gesetz
natürlich machte er verbotene sachen
aber so war er eben nicht nur bösartig
sondern auch chemisch das motto seiner
großeltern war übrigens
ort ist gut aber der teufel ist auch
nicht so schlecht
möglicherweise wird man nie erfahren wer
patsy morris ermordet hat aber sollte es
befiehlt gewesen sein dann wäre es nicht
sein letzter mord
im sommer 2004 verdient berg fährt sein
geld mit drogenhandel und dem anbringen
von parkkrallen
gewohnt seinen willen durchzusetzen hat
er sein umfeld völlig unter kontrolle
in seinem kleinen parkkrallen teams die
anderen fürchteten ihm
war gewalttätig und jähzornig dazu war
fähig sich aus jeder situation heraus zu
reden rief er seine mitarbeiter hinter
durch angst in schach
rodrigues damals sein mitbewohner und
freund versucht sich von ihm zu lösen
war so eine person wie jemand wie
battlefield ausnutzen konnte das war
nicht jedem möglich aber ein mensch wie
bayfield konnte ihn sehr leicht
manipulieren
johanna collins berrys ex freundin
hilfigers sich von ihnen zu trennen
juli hatte die schnauze voll von ihnen
er wollte daraus ohne dass lewis wusste
plante er zu mir zu ziehen rein
freundschaftlich bisher etwas anderes
finden konnte
doch bevor rodrigues ausziehen kann
gerät er mit bear field in streit
bayfield soll drogen in der wohnung von
rodrigues mutter versteckt haben während
diese im krankenhaus war
goodreader swift collins an
sagte ich gehe jetzt der dreht hier
völlig durch ich bin so ein etwa 20
minuten da im hintergrund hörte ich
lieber herumbrüllen
brach das gespräch ab
[Musik]
irgendwann rief mich die polizei an ob
ich jemanden namen split rodrigues
kennen würde ich sagte ja warum er wurde
mit einem hammer angegriffen ist auf der
intensivstation und musste drei mal
wiederbelebt werden
rodriguez kämpft in der klinik um sein
leben er liegt sechs wochen lang im koma
währenddessen befragt die polizei
verfehlt doch der bestreitet ihn
angegriffen zu haben da keine beweise
vorliegen lässt die polizei ihnen gehen
[Musik]
rapid war fest davon überzeugt dass
bayfield auf ihn eingeschlagen hat und
das wird sich wohl niemals beweisen
lassen er wurde nie angeklagt aber seine
letzte erinnerung ist die bälle viel
hinter ihm die treppe hinunterging er
könnte also mit seiner vermutung
durchaus richtig liegen
hartberg fehlt wirklich seinen freund
derart brutal angegriffen auf jeden fall
wird sein verhalten nun immer
rücksichtsloser er hat milly dowler
ermordet und kam davon
er hat marshall mcdonnell mit einem
hammer erschlagen und kam davon
und er hat mindestens noch einen
weiteren angriff verübt später wird er
mit weiteren in verbindung gebracht hält
sich bear fehlt mittlerweile für
unbesiegbar
sobald jemand merkt dass er mit seinen
taten davon kommt verliert er jegliche
hemmungen solche taten zu begehen so
kann die situation eskaliert
mitunter nutzen sich die befriedigenden
reize auch ab und dann muss man immer
weiter gehen um die selben gefühle von
macht und erregung zu bekommen
[Musik]
geht es ausschließlich um beherrschung
und kontrolle
als ich lieber kennenlernte war ich 18
vielleicht 19 jahre alt jeder hier
kannte ihren der gegend als harter hund
bekannt aber auch als einer der dir
immer aus der patsche helfen konnte
verfehlt hat das perfekte umfeld für
sich gefunden er kann den muskeln
spielen lassen und kontrolle ausüben
zu dieser zeit in den 1990 er jahren
setzt sich in großbritannien die
clubkultur durch
horden junger leute stehen schlange um
hineinzukommen für sie ist der türsteher
allmächtig der job ist wie gemacht für
verfehlt
dj liebte es türsteher zu sein selbst
wenn du hässlich bist und stinkt's
türsteher lieben nicht die mädchen
außerdem so ein nachtclub ist ein echtes
jagdrevier hunderte frauen und mädchen
zusammen gefertigt wie auf einem
viehmarkt hat die freie auswahl
collins ist fasziniert von
sehr sehr gut aussehen ganz anders als
jetzt er war gut gebaut wie schicke
autos mit immer geld und kleidete sich
gut alles stimmt
stundenlang befragt detektivs uday joan
collins und eine weitere ex freundin
emma mails so erfährt sie wie berg fehlt
die frauen in seinem leben manipulierte
lieber verstand es sehr gut die
schwächen anderer zu erkennen und
auszunutzen
zeigte sich sowohl in der beziehung zu
emma als auch in der 2
so kriegen sie dich geben dir das gefühl
die tollste frau der welt zu sein und
umwerben dich so dass du dich in sie
verliebt
dann aber ändern sie sich plötzlich und
zeigen ihr wahres gesicht
die heizölpreise all die geschenke
blumen also eine aufmerksamkeit anfangs
gab es keinerlei anzeichen seiner
gewalttätigkeit
nichts
doch das ändert sich eines tages
als er mich zum ersten mal richtig
schlug das im furchtbar leid er sagte
das sei nur weil er mich so lieben würde
wie er noch nie zuvor jemanden gelebt
hatte und ich habe ihm geglaubt weil er
fragen mich warum hast du ihn nicht
verlassen ich war so einfach ist das
nicht die kaum kam nicht und irgendwann
steckt man so tief drin dass man nicht
mehr herauskommt einwilligung war ein
fremdwort für ihn er hat sich genommen
was er wollte egal ob man ja oder nein
gesagt hat
[Musik]
man kann sich vorstellen wie es sich
anfühlt wenn du zu dir kommst und er auf
der liegt und auf dich einprügelt
vergewaltigt das lässt sich nicht in
worte fasst
war es passieren dass jemand andere
mahlzeit das gar nicht mein körper das
ging jahrelang so ewig immer weiter
als unfall war
[Musik]
kurz gesagt das war wie in einem
horrorfilm im verborgenen aber
misshandelt bell viert seine
partnerinnen nicht nur physisch
er war wirklich sehr grausam und auf
echte demütigung aus bei einer
gelegenheit zwang er seine partnerin zu
stundenlangen bewegungslosen sitzen auf
einem küchen hocker davon rückte er auch
dann nicht ab als sie irgendwann zur
toilette musste
offenbar deutlich machen dass sie völlig
hilf und wertlos war dies bestärkte ihn
wohl in dem glauben seine macht ausüben
und völlig ungestraft bösartig sein zu
können
es wurde schnell deutlich wie gefährlich
und gewalttätig perfekt war
wenn er sich schon zu hause in einer
beziehung so aufführt ohne jedes
anzeichen von reue da fragt man sich
wozu ist dann noch in der lage was hat
er noch getan
[Applaus]
nur eine woche vor der attacke auf
seinen freund pedro rodrigues streift
berg fehlt erneut in seinem wagen durch
die straßen der jugendliche katy ist
derweil unterwegs und feiert ihren
letzten schultag vor den
abschlussprüfungen
[Musik]
nach mitternacht geht bei der polizei
ein ungewöhnlicher notruf ein
[Musik]
eine junge frau ist überfahren worden
die anruferin ist cage idee
[Musik]
hat die ereignisse jener nacht für die
metropolitan police untersucht
patrick head weintrinken herr mit
freunden etwas trinken dann haben sie
den bus der linie haar zahlen 20 nach
hause nach eisels
auf dem heimweg fiel ihr ein weißer wenn
mit verdunkelten scheiben auf sie hatte
ein merkwürdiges gefühl dabei und
wechselte die straßenseite um nicht an
dem fahrzeug vorbei zu müssen als sie
die straße überquerte drehte das
fahrzeug plötzlich und fuhr sie an kate
lag unter dem auto als der rückwärtsgang
eingelegt und sie nochmals überfahren
wurde danach fuhr einfach davon
kate wurde auf der straße schwer
verletzt liegengelassen furchtbar der
albtraum aller eltern
die die überlebt diese tortur nur knapp
der notruf hat ihr das leben gerettet
[Musik]
zur gleichen zeit hat die polizei mit
einem weiteren ungelösten fall zu tun
der allerdings fordert ein todesopfer
hierauf der priory road fand der brutale
überfall statt den ganzen tag über sind
menschen gekommen um blumen für mascha
mcdonnell abzulegen die menschen hier
sind geschockt und verängstigt die
polizei tappt im dunkeln der mörder von
maria befindet sich weiter auf freiem
fuß
der fall ist völlig offen wir ermitteln
in alle richtungen
wir können das motiv nicht sonst wären
mit der lösung schon einen schritt näher
[Applaus]
im august 2004 wird die französische
studentin amelie dollar grosch in
twickenham green ermordet keine fünf
kilometer vom fundort der leiche mascha
mcdonald's
drei fälle mit deutlichen parallelen
innerhalb von 18 monaten erfolgten drei
nächtliche überfälle auf drei junge
blonde frauen jedes mal nach dem
verlassen eines autobusses an drei nur
acht kilometer voneinander entfernten
tatorten
[Musik]
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass mehr als
eine person in derselben gegend auf
dieselbe art vorgeht ist ehrlich gesagt
kaum vorstellbar
[Applaus]
und die informationen die die ermittler
auf bayfields spur bringt kommt aus
seinem umfeld
es war wohl meine aussage die die sache
ins rollen brachte sie lautete wie folgt
johannes ex freund mit dem sie zusammen
lebte heißt liebe erfährt johanna
zufolge hasst er blonde frauen und als
sie sich vor sieben jahren trennten fand
sie einen schwarzen nannte in der garage
in dessen innentasche ein messer und
eine sturmhaube versteckt waren sowie
eine cosmopolitan ausgabe in der die
gesichter aller blonden frauen
zerschnitten bruder zerstochen waren
ich nannte das sein vergewaltiger set
ich wusste dass er blondinen abgrundtief
haste denn er sagte mir dass ständig ich
weiß nicht warum er hatte einfach enorm
hass auf sie
verfehlt wird festgenommen und angeklagt
mich überkam ein wirklich äußerst
befremdliches gefühl als ich von seiner
verhaftung erfuhr er war schließlich
jahrelang ein teil meines lebens gewesen
aspecta vollständig an meinem haus
vorbei rief mich an tauchte immer
irgendwo auf
das ist auch wieder eine form der
kontrolle er hatte so viel einfluss und
macht ein leben das ich mich ganz
hilflos fühlte als er nicht mehr da war
totale psychospielchen
2008 wird live per viel schuldig
gesprochen für die morde an amelie
dollar grosch und mascha mcdonnell sowie
für den versuchten mord an cage idee die
im verfahren gegen ihn ausgesagt hat
[Musik]
natürlich werde ich nie vergessen können
was mir widerfahren ist die erinnerungen
werde ich nie abschütteln aber ich hoffe
dass ich darüber hinweg komme sie
spricht auch über die familien der
frauen die befehls angriffe nicht
überlegt haben ich hoffe dass das urteil
den familien die so unter den
abscheulichen taten dieses mannes zu
leiden haben etwas trost spendet
doch das volle ausmaß seiner taten ist
noch gar nicht bekannt
bei der überprüfung von bayfields
vergangenheit machen die ermittler eine
dramatische entdeckung
er hat einstmals nur wenige meter von
einem berüchtigten tatort entfernt
gewohnt
der fall milly dowler ist einer der
grössten mord ermittlungen in der
geschichte dieses landes ist tief im
öffentlichen bewusstsein verankert
mit coaches los als junger mann träumt
david collins von einer karriere als
reporter und mit 26 jahren ergreift der
ehrgeizige volontär seine chance beim
daily mirror
erhielt vor gericht stand war ich
nachwuchsreporter in der
nachrichtenredaktion
ich las in der zeitung dass liverpool
fühlt als hauptverdächtiger im fall
milly dowler galt
sah sich in der redaktion und bei einer
zeitung wie dem mirror gehen ständig
anrufe aus der bevölkerung ein mit tipps
oder hinweisen was wir uns mal ansehen
sollten
an dem tag rief mich jemand an und sagte
er hätte eine story
und es stellte sich heraus dass die
treibende kraft hinter dieser story die
welt war
[Musik]
der mittelsmann am telefon steht in
direkter verbindung zu viert für collins
könnte dies der erhoffte durchbruch sein
fragt ihr den mittelsmann wäre lieber
fehlt wohl interessiert mir ein
interview zu geben
[Musik]
ein paar tage später kam der anruf ja
sie bei bir fühlt ist interessiert
doch david collins soll sich erst einmal
beweisen verfehlt behält die kontrolle
selbst hinter gittern er will die
aufmerksamkeit der medien aber zunächst
stellt er den reporter auf die probe
um 22.30 rief ein freund von bayfield an
fahren sie jetzt zu diesem wohnblock
seien sie innerhalb der nächsten stunde
da denn es wartet ein paket von bayfield
auf sie das sollen sie abholen er wusste
ich nicht
was ich musste mich entscheiden fahre
ich zu diesem wohnblock im süden londons
um das paket abzuholen oder nicht mir
war klar was die redakteure meiner
zeitung sagen würden das kannst du nicht
machen es ist halb elf uhr abends das
könnte eine falle sein
bayfield mich übertölpeln war dass seine
rache für alles was die medien über ihn
verbreitet hatten wartete da vielleicht
ein schlägertrupp auf mich
ich fuhr also zu diesem wohnblock in süd
london
ich kannte diese gegend nicht und es war
kurz vor mitternacht ich klopfe an mir
wurde geöffnet und in einem zimmer
voller rauchschwaden saßen verwandte und
freunde von berlin
collins wird ein päckchen mit fotos und
einem handgeschriebenen brief von
bayfield übergeben
auf etwa zwölf seiten legt er dar dass
er nichts mit den morden an massa und
amelie zu tun hat auch nicht an dem
mordversuch an katy die angeblich hatte
ihn die polizei hereingelegt
da wird collins klar warum berg fehlt
einem interview zugestimmt hat
levi's ziel war es sich in den augen der
öffentlichkeit zu entlasten
ich sollte ihm die plattform bieten
sagen zu können ich bin unschuldig
collins hartberg als erster test
bestanden die nächste hürde ist es
bertels familie zu überzeugen als
bruder richard stellte mich der mutter
vor sie war tatsächlich der schlüssel
sie war erkennbar die unangefochtene
material in dieser familie
sie die mutter musste ich überzeugen es
war praktisch eine vorladung zur
herrscherin der familie berg
von nun an besucht collins die familie
regelmäßig und gewinnt nach und nach das
vertrauen seiner mutter ging
das telefon klingelte als ich mit den
gerade roastbeef sandwiches
levi's bruder nahm ab und lee war am
apparat ich fragte wird er mit mir
sprechen lee war dazu bereit ihn kannte
mich mittlerweile und viel mich zu mögen
denn sie willigte ein
doch bert fields plan stellt eine letzte
forderung collins soll schriftlich
versichern ausschließlich in levi's
bestem sind zu handeln
ich musste an ort und stelle eine
schnelle entscheidung treffen
unterzeichne ich das komme ich so liebe
erfüllt um ihn als erster überhaupt zum
milly dowler zu befragen
das war damals noch nicht einmal der
polizei gelungen es war die erste
gelegenheit ihm auf den zahn zu fühlen
wo sind sie an diesem tag gewesen
collins besiegelt die abmachung und
unterzeichnet er bekommt sein interview
mit dem serientäter
[Musik]
viel steht auf dem spiel die behörden
hoffen zum fall milly dowler auf eine
entscheidende aussage
[Musik]
seine anrufe wurden stets von polizei
und gefängnisleitung abgehört man hörte
dass klicken in der leitung wenn sie
sich dazu schalteten
[Musik]
als ich mit ihm sprach dachte ich grad
das ist ja wie im film die ganze familie
saß um mich herum und beobachtete mich
mit argusaugen während sie zu hören ich
saß mit all diesen leuten in einem
zimmer und telefonierte mit einem
serienmörder
[Musik]
seine art zu sprechen zeigt er
beansprucht die kontrolle über das
gespräch ständig sagt der dinge wie
können sie mir folgen
so muss er versucht sein gegenüber zu
steuern und zu überwachen
wie erwartet nutzt bayfield das gespräch
zur beteuerung seiner unschuld
[Musik]
doch collins verliert sein ziel nicht
aus den augen verliert nach milly dowler
zu fragen ein roter day wo ist in der
nähe ihres entführungs ortes gesehen
worden die ermittler wissen dass
bayfield an jenem tag ein solches auto
fuhr aber können sie auch beweisen dass
er der fahrer auf den
überwachungsaufnahmen ist wenn er es
zugeben würde das wäre ein knüller
umberg fehlt zu überlisten erwähnt
collins beiläufig den roten wagen
[Musik]
die daumen
die frage über den roten der eu war
meine letzte an ihn an diesen fraglichen
tag war er eine halbe stunde nach -
verschwinden in die station avenue
eingebogen und seine antwort auf meine
frage werde ich niemals vergessen
[Musik]
wer fehlt gab damit endlich zu den wagen
auf den überwachungsaufnahmen gefahren
zu haben dieser eine antwort auf diese
eine frage das war der knackpunkt
da wusste ich dass er mich getötet hat
und so klar war dass zu diesem zeitpunkt
wohl niemandem sonst im ganzen land
es ist geschafft collins hat seine story
er übergibt die aufnahmen der polizei
bayfield ist überführt
[Musik]
die britische boulevardpresse hat damit
auch gelegenheit sich nach dem
abhörskandal zu rehabilitieren
[Musik]
ja ich bin ein risiko eingegangen aber
das war es wert es hat sich gelohnt es
hat gezeigt dass journalismus gutes
bewirken kann dieses gespräch mit bild
hat mein ganzes leben verändert
2016 gibt die serie police bekannt
verfehlt habe den mord an milly dowler
endlich gestanden
es hat beinahe 14 jahre gedauert aber
nun hat liebert die entführung
vergewaltigung und ermordung der
schülerin milly dowler gestanden
2002 haben ihr verschwinden und ihr tod
das land erschüttert für minis
angehörige es dieses geständnis sehr
schmerzhaft ein weiterer schlag für eine
familie die schon so viel hat ertragen
müssen
doch nur wenige wochen später widerruft
verfehlt das geständnis einmal mehr
scheint es als habe er die kontrolle sie
fühlen sich mächtig wenn sie meinen die
situation kontrollieren zu können
vielleicht sage ich dir etwas vielleicht
überlege ich es mir anders und sage dir
nichts da geht es nur um kontrolle und
macht
der bergfahrt albtraum will einfach kein
ende nehmen und jeder der mit ihm zu tun
hat ahnt dass noch lange nicht alles
bekannt ist
[Musik]
im gespräch mit ihm nantes jagen der
jagte frauen die allein an haltestellen
in bussen oder zu fuß unterwegs waren er
war auf jeden fall von 2002 bis zu
seiner festnahme aktiv und wer weiß wie
lange schon davor
verfehlt hat auch david collins in
seinen bann gezogen den journalisten
lässt der fall nicht los und er stößt
auf eine geheimakte die das enorme
ausmaß von übergriffen enthüllt mit
denen verfehlt in verbindung gebracht
wird
ich hatte zugang zu einer geheimen
polizeiakte in der es um das ausmaß von
bayfields straftaten im vereinigten
königreich gingen
sämtliche fälle in denen frauen in einem
bestimmten zeitraum mit stumpfen
gegenständen angegriffen wurden waren
durch polizei computer ausgewertet
worden dabei zeigte sich dass es
häufungen in bestimmten gegenden gab
gegenden in die bayfield verbindungen
hatte
[Musik]
aus der geheimakte geht verblüffendes
hervor bayfield galt bei neuen
überfällen als verdächtiger außerdem bei
einer reihe von vergewaltigungen und
übergriffen die nie vor gericht kamen
insgesamt hatte es 24 gewalttätige
übergriffe auf frauen gegeben viele von
ihnen wussten nicht dass bayfield als
verdächtig kite
war sicher für viel mehr übergriffe
verantwortlich als man ihm letztlich
nachweisen konnte
wir hatten damals einfach zu wenige
beweise
ich bin überzeugt dass liverpool fehlt
einer der gefährlichsten frauenmörder
war die england die gesehen hat
hätte die metropolitan police ihn damals
nicht gefasst werden durch ihn mit
sicherheit weitere verbrechen verübt
worden er hätte noch mehr frauen getötet
und niemals damit aufgehört
er verspürte ständig diesen starken
drang los zu ziehen und nach opfern
ausschau zu halten vorzugsweise nach
jungen frauen dann griff er sie brutal
ohne jeden ersichtlichen grund an es
waren auch nicht immer sexuelle
übergriffe er ging einfach mit brutaler
mörderischer gewalt vor
isabel friedt verübte ein verbrechen
nach dem anderen
wir werden nie das ganze ausmaß von
bayfields taten erfahren die jahre
vergehen doch collins kann im fallberg
fehlt noch immer nicht nachgeben er ist
überzeugt dass dessen bösartigkeit noch
sehr viel tiefer geht
ich hatte das gefühl ihn zu kennen wie
sonst niemand in den folgenden monaten
und jahren ging collins weiteren
geschichten und gerüchten über bayfield
nach
ich sprach mit leuten aus dem
kriminellen milieu auch mit
schrotthändlern mit seinen
geschäftspartnern mit verurteilten
pädophilen eben mit allen möglichen
leuten mit denen sich perfid umgeben
hatte
noch ahnt collins nicht was er aufdecken
wird
[Musik]
ich bekam einen neuen fall auf den tisch
auf dem betreff viel mehr liebe fierce
nahm auf denn ich wusste natürlich dass
er wegen des mordes an milly dowler in
haft war
2016 arbeitet dead rising im londoner
bezirk killing dann als beauftragte für
fragen sexuellen kindesmissbrauchs in
ihrem neuen fall geht es um eine
schwangere jugendliche
junge frau lebte in einer beziehung mit
einem von libreoffice geschäftspartnern
diese sache sage ich mir genauer an es
kam ein riesiges netzwerk zum vorschein
er ist kurze zeit zuvor haben die
missbrauchsskandale von roger hammond jr
das land erschüttert organisierte banden
hatten in diesen nordenglischen städten
über jahre hinweg schulmädchen und
jugendliche insassen staatliche
betreuungseinrichtungen mit drogen und
alkohol gefügig gemacht dann wurden sie
missbraucht vergewaltigt und einfach
weitergereicht für derby die in ihrem
früheren job bei der stadtverwaltung von
peter boro maßgeblich an der aufdeckung
eines pädophilen rings beteiligt war ein
vertrautes bild
ich fand heraus dass zwei banden in
einer bestimmten straße aktiv waren
teilte meine erkenntnisse der cambridger
police mit
die gemeinsame untersuchung durch stadt
und polizei ermittelt in und um
peterborough zahlreiche opfer
diese blase platzte die sache wurde
richtig groß
letztlich wurden mehrere männer
angeklagt
aber es ging mir nicht um einen erfolg
sondern um die gute zusammenarbeit und
um den mut der jungen frauen die sich
gemeldet und ausgesagt hatte kam
freising fürchtet nun es in ihrem neuen
zuständigkeitsbereich im westen londons
mit ähnlichen verbrechen zu tun zu haben
derby war eine erfahrene
sozialarbeiterin die solche banken
bereits erfolgreich bekämpft und
unschädlich gemacht hatte
sie könnte sich also aus sie hatte
erfahrung und sie spielte eine wichtige
rolle in hellen
nach monatelangem recherchearbeiten in
ihrer freizeit legt racing ihre
erkenntnisse in einem bericht dar
darin erläutert sie das lieber
battlefield mitglied einer grooming
bande war die gemeinschaftlich für den
missbrauch von 17 jungen frauen und
mädchen verantwortlich war
wie schon in la bohème standen elf von
ihnen unter staatlicher betreuung
xing geht den anschuldigungen nach
rwe hatte zugang zu den akten des
sozialamtes und so aussagen von
missbrauchsopfern
sie hatte auch zugang zu vertraulichen
informationen über bayfield partner aus
pädophilen kreisen
[Musik]
bei meinen untersuchungen erkannte ich
dass bayfield nicht allein gehandelt hat
auf einigen informationen zufolge waren
seine geschäftspartner beteiligt
es wurde deutlich dass im londoner
westen vor allem in heiligendamm seit
jahren ein pädophilen ring aktiv ist
sagt ihre beweise reichten bis ins jahr
2002 zurück in ihrem bericht werden
sieben männer als potenziell verdächtig
eingestuft und der bekannteste unter
ihnen ist limitiert
withings recherche bringt verfehlt mit
zwei männern in verbindung die wegen
sexualdelikten an kindern verurteilt
worden waren
2005 wurde viktor kelly verurteilt weil
er einer zwölfjährigen kokain im
austausch für sex angeboten hatte
ich konnte die zusammenarbeit von victor
kelly und liebert nachweisen
verbindungen bestanden über auto und
ein anderer name auf den weißen im
zusammenhang mit bayfield immer wieder
stößt
2005 wird garou verhaftet nachdem er ein
kind ohne gesetzliche erlaubnis mit nach
hause genommen und zu sexuellen
aktivitäten animiert hat
zu diesem zeitpunkt war weiß elz bericht
noch geheim aber bayfield scheint darin
zutreffend beschrieben
[Musik]
war man mit ihm im auto unterwegs rief
er jungen mädchen immer beleidigungen
hinterher
war unfassbar peinlich
teenagern schulmädchen an
bushaltestellen und auf der straße bist
du noch jungfrau ich würde dich [ __ ]
solchen dreck geben
es war ihm egal wie es anderen damit
ging für
ihn war seine art sport
am 20 oktober 2017 übergibt weißen ihren
bericht der bezirksverwaltung heling
kann sie nimmt an ihre arbeit sei getan
und es würden nun festnahmen folgen doch
ein volles jahr später
[Applaus]
nichts
im oktober 2017 reichte ich mein bericht
ein und im dezember 2018 kam die sunday
times zu mir ein ganzes jahr später
david collins arbeitet inzwischen für
die sunday times und hat einen anonymen
hinweis auf weiß einst geheimen helling
dem bericht erhalten
nach dem gespräch mit ihr schreibt er
eine story und lässt sie am 30 dezember
2018 drucken
sie wird von allen anderen zeitungen
aufgegriffen
[Musik]
ich recherchierte ausführlich zu
benfield und stellte fest dass er nicht
nur gemordet sondern alles mögliche
getan hatte
[Musik]
der helling dann bericht scheint collins
schlimmste befürchtungen zu bestätigen
ich glaube etwas bestimmtes in berlins
charakter wurde noch nicht eingehend
untersucht
mich hat diese frage allerdings immer
schon beschäftigt
war er teil einer grooming bande die
minderjährige mädchen verführte und
missbrauchte
gerade dem ist weiter nachgegangen
mittlerweile steht hinten durch ihre
arbeit im blickpunkt der öffentlichkeit
sie weiß es wird noch mehr arbeit auf
sie zukommen die öffentliche diskussion
über ihren bericht lässt weiß sein
hoffen hoffen dass mehr getan wird um
missbrauchs opfern zu helfen doch ob die
ermittlungen dahingehend weiter gehen
weiß sie nicht
im dezember 2018 reagiert die polizei
auf zeitungsberichte mit folgender
stellungnahme
ein bericht der bezirksverwaltung
ländern ist eingegangen alle darin
enthaltenen anschuldigungen sexuellen
kindesmissbrauchs werden geprüft und
gegebenenfalls untersucht die
bezirksverwaltung helling dann äußert
sich dazu wie folgt nach fertigstellung
des berichts wurden die informationen
gemeinsam mit der metropolitan police
gründlich überprüft um eine zügige
angemessene reaktion sicherzustellen
die frage war welche kreise zog das
ganze wie viele leute waren darin
verstrickt wie viele mädchen waren
betroffen ich denke diese frage ist noch
immer nicht beantwortet
doch nachdem collins sunday times und
andere überregionale zeitungen die story
gebracht haben wendet sich die
metropolitan police an weiß er wird man
zu einem meeting mit der met eingeladen
und alles was sie sagen ist ja wir haben
den bericht bekommen oh ja wir gehen der
sache nach dieser beamte hier ist dafür
zuständig
für die seit jahren mit jungen
missbrauchsopfern arbeitet drängt die
zeit
es ist einfach falsch und das ist
unfassbar frustrierend ich habe mich
verpflichtet kinder und jugendliche zu
schützen was machen denn alle anderen
oder was haben sie gemacht habe ich kann
es nicht sehen
in der stellungnahme der
bezirksverwaltung hier linden von 2018
heißt es weiter ein speziell
ausgebildeter polizist wurde eigens zur
untersuchung der informationen
abgestellt dass kinderschutz team der
bezirksverwaltung ländern hat zahlreiche
überprüfungen durchgeführt und sich mit
allen betroffenen behörden in verbindung
gesetzt
doch nun sind weiß sings bericht und
ihren namen öffentlich bekannt immer
mehr opfer brechen ihr schweigen
ich konnte nicht einfach sagen okay das
war's mir reicht's ich gehe ich musste
diesen mädchen und frauen helfen
racing setzt sich weiter nach kräften
für die opfer ein aber nicht mehr allein
eine kollegin unterstützt sie jetzt
sie möchte anonym bleiben
daher wird sie hier einfach als jane
bezeichnet
das sind sehr gefährliche männer
sie sind bis heute eine schwere
bedrohung für jeden der sich ihnen in
den weg zu stellen versucht
ich bin im westen von london geboren ich
kenne mich also dort aus ich habe viele
jahre bezirke linken und der umgebung
gearbeitet
ich habe als erzieherin fürsorge kinder
im alter von 16 bis 18 jahren
unterstützt
ihre immer bewusst dass es in der gegend
triebtäter gab
allerdings war mir nicht klar dass sie
nie zur rechenschaft gezogen wurden und
einfach immer weitermachen
ernte habe ich nicht an können wie viele
jugendliche und kinder in unseren 18
monaten der zusammenarbeit davon
betroffen sein wird
beide frauen gehen den fällen in ihrer
freizeit nach im juli 2019 beschließen
sie den weg über die politik zu
versuchen die stimme der opfer soll auf
jeden fall zu hören sein sie bitten um
ein treffen mit ihrem zuständigen
abgeordneten der abgeordnete für ax
bridge ist diesen sommer sehr
beschäftigt
[Musik]
boris johnson schreiben denn helling dax
bridge ist sein eigener wahlkreis
uns erschien wichtig ihm über die
vorfälle in seinem zuständigkeitsbereich
in kenntnis zu setzen
wenige tage bevor er das amt des
premierministers übernimmt stimmt er
einem treffen zu
[Musik]
johnson erklärte sich bereit dafür
nachher linken zu kommen wir trafen ihn
im gemeindezentrum
beschreibt es als ausführliches gespräch
er hört sich ihre sorgen an
ich werde nie vergessen was er mir beim
verlassen des gemeindezentrums sagt er
er sagte
anschließend fordert der premierminister
die bezirksverwaltung hehlingen
schriftlich zu weiterer zusammenarbeit
mit der polizei auf um die
anschuldigungen gründlich zu untersuchen
darauf antwortet hilden wains
empfehlungen seien umgesetzt man würde
gemeinsam mit der polizei allen
anschuldigungen nachgehen
derweil arbeiten weiß sang und jane
weiter an der aufklärung des falls es
melden sich immer mehr junge frauen
ist auch anfangs waren es fünf jetzt
sind es 24
es könnten 50 oder 60 junge menschen
sein die silhouetten stehen für die
opfer und überlebenden mit denen rising
und jane gesprochen haben
wenn man sich das so anschaut es ist
unglaublich und alles fing mit der wies
berichte wir wissen beide nicht welche
ausmaße das ganze annehmen wird es rufen
noch jeden tag menschen an ich habe noch
eine und noch eine baby hör dir an was
diese frau zu sagen hat und immer so
weiter
hört das auf
aber alles für zurück zum selben anfang
sich all die schilderungen anzuhören
fordert seinen tribut
ich werde weiterhin für diese frauen
stark sein denn genau das ist nötig sie
wurden so lange allein gelassen jeden
tag melden sich junge frauen und immer
zu sagen sie das gleiche wir wollten
doch nur dass uns jemand zuhört und wenn
ich nicht an gerechtigkeit glauben würde
die wurde an den richtigen umgang damit
ich würde es nicht machen aber
jetzt endlich hört man ihnen zu dank der
unterstützung durch rising und jane
sie liefern neue details zur dunklen
vergangenheit eines serientäters
[Musik]
erstmals ist eine der frauen zur aussage
vor der kamera bereit
[Musik]
vielen dank dass sie heute mit mir
sprechen ich bin ihnen sehr dankbar ich
hoffe sie wissen dass
für alles was sie für mich getan haben
sie wandte sich an weißen nachdem sie in
der presse von ihrem bericht gelesen
hatte einige namen kannte sie aus ihrer
jugendzeit
der bericht zeichnet die verbindung
zwischen ihnen
das hat mich richtig erschreckt
sie waren nie zuvor in den medien ist
teil desselben pädophilenrings genannt
worden
ich dachte das kann nicht wahr sein
im laufe der jahre wurden sachen über
lieber bekannt und überlegt und dann las
ich dass und dachte dabei das hat
tatsächlich eine sozialarbeiterin
verfasst
der inzwischen inhaftierte viktor weg
kelly ist ebenso wie bayfield ein von
weiß sein identifiziertes mitglied
derselben bande
die erste begegnung mit weg hatte ich
mit ungefähr 13
ich war weg gelaufen und er kam mit
seinem mitsubishi shogun angefahren
es war ein kurzes aufeinandertreffen
der junge bei dem ich übernachtete saß
auf der rückbank
und weg versuchte über den seitenspiegel
blickkontakt mit mir aufzunehmen
dieser junge hatte mich bereits gewarnt
seine begrüßung nicht zu erwidern
also machte ich das auch nicht aber ich
fühlte mich sehr unwohl weil er mich
ständig über den spiegel an starter und
versuchte blickkontakt aufzunehmen
kelly in der gegend bekannt ja auch dass
er auf ganz junge stand er hatte immer
einen schwarm von mädchen um sich herum
und
[Musik]
wie alt waren diese mädchen ihrer
meinung nach
das kann ich ihnen genau sagen
[Musik]
als sie ein jahr später in einem
kinderheim untergebracht ist lauert ein
weiterer mann auf opfer ich war knapp 14
hat sich in dem heim wohnte es hieß
immer halte ich von dem fernseher ist
total gestört
also ging man lieber aus dem weg da kam
immer an bushaltestellen herangefahren
wenn dort mädchen standen das konnte man
häufig sehen
[Musik]
doch per viert geübtem manipulieren
bringt oft andere dazu für ihn die
drecksarbeit zu erledigen
sie haben es auf die schwächsten
abgesehen
wir wussten einfach wo sie jetzt
versuchen hatten sie hat nicht nur einen
kleinen bereich im visier sondern den
ganzen stadtteil und noch weiter darüber
hinaus
die mädchen wurden mit gras koks und
alkohol gefügig gemacht
sie hatten es auf die abgesehen die wie
wir auch nicht viel hatten sie
brachten sie dann zu liebe und der
machte mit ihnen was er wollte
wissen sie was mit diesem mädchen
geschehen ist
man brachte sie in eine wohnung ein
händler
ihnen wurden ghb oder holt 0 verabreicht
dann wechselten sich alle an ihnen ab
und das ganze wurde gefilmt sie
haben diese mädchen wie objekte benutzt
und sich dabei abgewechselt
vor allem ein verstörendes erlebnis ist
ihr in erinnerung geblieben mann wurde
zur wohnung geordert ich war einmal dort
ging rein rief den flur entlang machte
die tür auf und dachte nur oh mein gott
da war eine ganze horde von ihnen im
wohnzimmer
waren diese mädchen wohl
14 13 14
da waren also bekannte von bayfield in
einer wohnung mit jungen mädchen
eines tages rastet sie aus sie stellt
bear viel zur rede
ich sagte ihm dass er ein pädophiler sei
zum glück hat er mich nicht umgebracht
was erwiderte liebe als sie ihnen einen
pädophilen nannten
das tor stand nur da und grinste stand
einfach nur grinsen da
war beängstigend
stand vor diesem mann und beschimpfte
ihn als pädophilen und gott weiß was
noch alles und bin noch am leben
es lässt einem das blut in den adern
gefrieren denn man denkt oh mein gott er
hat mich so angeschaut weil er wusste
dass er mich umbringen würde
das ist ihnen passiert als sie ein kind
waren
[Musik]
inzwischen sind sie erwachsen aber
diese männer beherrschen in gewisser
weise noch immer ihren alltag
ja das wird wohl auch immer so bleiben
[Musik]
sie hatten alles unter kontrolle
egal wohin man ging egal ob man dachte
dass man sie abgeschüttelt hätte
[Musik]
immer wieder ich kann nicht vor die tür
gehen ich habe angst ich fürchte mich
vor meinem eigenen schatten ich habe
flashbacks ich wache morgens auf und
fühle mich als sei wieder jemand über
mich hergefallen
ich habe es so sagt mich als opfer zu
fühlen zu denken dass ich es hätte
besser wissen müssen ich habe es so satt
und so geht es sicher auch anderen
manchen mädchen hat das so zugesetzt
dass sie sich vielleicht niemals mehr
davon erholen
warum müssen wir dies können darüber
sprechen
[Musik]
es gibt verbrechen dieser art und es ist
mehr als wahrscheinlich dass es viele
weitere davon gibt diese leute wurden
nie zur verantwortung gezogen sie sind
noch immer auf freiem fuß sie machen
unbehelligt einfach weiter
[Musik]
wakefield war überzeugt jeden in seinem
umfeld kontrollieren zu können seine
geschäftspartner die presse selbst die
polizei nur sich selbst konnte er nicht
kontrollieren
wahrscheinlich wird niemals bekannt wie
viele gewalttätige und tödliche angriffe
er vor den drei morden verübte für die
er schließlich verurteilt wurde
womöglich wird einigen opfern niemals
gerechtigkeit zuteil
doch für eine gruppe von frauen gibt es
hoffnung
[Musik]
ich werde für die frauen die ausgesagt
haben immer weiterkämpfen
mit unterstützung und ermutigung werden
die frauen die man zum schweigen
gebracht hat nun endlich gehört
[Musik]
was möchten sie anderen frauen mit auf
den weg geben
ganz gleich für wie unbedeutend ihres
haltet bitte sagt aus denn wenn wir
nicht alle gemeinschaftlich aussagen
werden sie ungestraft davonkommen
[Musik]